en afrique dans la province soudanaise
du darfour se déroule un désastre
humanitaire dans un certain silence que
veut dénoncer ce week-end la communauté
internationale plusieurs manifestations
sont prévues en europe et aux états unis
trois cent mille morts en trois ans deux
millions et demi de déplacés
il est urgent d'agir jérôme soûlard
trois ans de guerres et de souffrances
pour les populations noires minoritaire
du darfour
trois en exil insupportable pour des
centaines de milliers de civils entassés
dans des camps de fortune depuis 2003 la
guerre la sécheresse et les maladies ont
tué trois cent mille civils dans le sud
soudan
deux millions et demi de personnes sont
déplacées malgré les risques importants
des milliers de réfugiés quittent
aujourd'hui les camps pour rejoindre
leur village plus au nord je ne suis pas
sûr de retrouver ma maison je ne crois
pas je suis très inquiète mais
l'essentiel pour nous c'est de rester en
vie chez eux pourtant ils retrouveront
la guerre les villages brûlés et les
rebelles en armes de la ls qui tentent
de défendre leur terre les combats sont
féroces contre l'armée régulière du
soudan à majorité arabe accusée des
pires exactions contre les civils noirs
du darfour partout dans le monde
aujourd'hui des voix s'élèvent dénonçant
un génocide
exigeant de l'onu un déploiement
immédiat des casques bleus
pendant que nous discutons ici des gens
meurent dans la honte et l'humiliation
n'attendez pas l'invitation du
gouvernement du soudan pour intervenir
allez-y sans intervention de l'onu
l'armée du soudan pourrait continuer ces
exactions contre les civils du darfour 7
millions de personnes sont prisonnières
de ce conflit sans témoin au liban